said these people say they don't enjoy
life they say well you know you can take
your life away in an instant why are you
living first of all there's no such
thing as not not enjoying your life
because we can just take it away you
don't enjoy it take away don't complain
dude these new-age secret gurus are the
worst today we're talking about Eric ho
or the artist formerly known as Eric oh
now you can find them on YouTube as
master Shri ash Khurana or something
like that it had to go with the eastern
names so the Westerners will believe how
spiritual he is and I discovered this
guy because actually one of you sent me
a message about him and you sent me the
following
I have lost a huge sum of money twenty
thousand pounds to one guru and with me
was a bunch of single mothers a recently
divorced nourished bankrupted plumber
etc who were all going through tough
times in their life I was going through
a difficult time too in my career
however nothing compared to those women
now this got me interested so I looked
into Eric ho and it turns out he's this
spiritual guru whatnot he's always
preaching about the secret which if you
don't know it's like this Law of
Attraction thing from way back basically
it's so stupid the idea is that you
manifest in your life of what you want
and so if you just envision it you can
like do it and gosh I know I know that
sounds like crazy right because if that
were true why are there kids starving in
Africa oh well it's just because they're
not manifesting well shockingly Eric
believes just that it will be watching
videos like this won't like the sound of
that
especially when the thinking of people
in those dire situations where they are
victims right now but if you we could
actually come to this realization and
this awareness and this consciousness
that actually we are creating everything
it means that there are no victims he
says in one of his videos he tries to
explain why you're broke and why why
people aren't wealthy he says it's your
fault
for a lot of people to actually manifest
what they want especially when they are
in the lack of something and when
they're in the lack of something they're
always in need for something but when
you're in need of something that's
scarcity mindset that's why bro this
dude is so insufferable he's standing in
front of a Lamborghini trying to preach
to you about that your your scarcity
mindsets holding you back
give me a break dude you're wealthy
you're healthy and you're gonna be
preaching to everyone else about how
that's just their mindset holding them
back a lot of people actually end up
fighting for the things they want in
life and when you fight you need to
understand when you fight in one this is
just a natural principle what fights
always fights back so fighting doesn't
actually work the whole process is we
need to learn to trust and let go
because when we let go what happens is
is opening up the hands to allow the
energy so as you travel out for the
energies to actually come in bro those
African kids who are starving
I think Eric Ho needs to go tell them
that they just need to let go so the
energy will go out of their hand and
come back to them and feed them right
because that's how it works you know we
need to tell those kids just envision
envision manifest that chicken in your
stomach okay a little chicken will grow
there if you manifest it you don't need
to strive why are you striving you just
need to trust that the universe is gonna
put a little Turkey and your Tumtum this
is the basic laws of vibration and the
basic laws of attraction see yeah this
is just super offensive stuff but what
gets me was not that I mean that's just
kind of all over YouTube right now for
some reason and it gets hundreds of
thousands of views by the way which is
incredible to me but there's a lot more
than just that he is really how he makes
his money is not by these little videos
about the secret and why you're broke or
whatever the real way he makes his money
is by selling you a course in the past
it was this thing called manifesting
miracles right now it's this thing
called wealthy guru and the price is
this guy is charging is absurd he's
charging between five thousand and
fifteen thousand pounds to go to these
events they think how insane that is
oh man hearing this hearing this guy try
to spiritualize this is
amazing it's it's so incredible and it
just shows you why these guys are the
worst these guys are the absolute worst
at least with Dan lock I know why he
wants he just wants my money don't this
guy's trying to like spiritualize it oh
yeah I just you know I need I need your
money right
people always ask they say Master when
we come to your your events or your or
your training or your coaching why is it
that you have to charge for it and it's
not that I wants to charge for it dude
look at that smile it's not that I want
to charge for it and it's not that I
wants to charge for it when it comes to
a point of supply and demand you have
there is no other option really if it
was free I would need to keep bringing
money out of my pocket to pay for all
these different menus and I don't have
another option I have to charge you ten
thousand pounds right I have to I have
two guys it's not because I want to it's
because I have to as your spiritual
leader I need to do this right supply
and demand baby how am I supposed to
afford the Lambo I'm trying to manifest
my own dreams here keep bringing money
out of my pocket to pay for all these
different venues and that shouldn't be a
problem right if you can just manifest
it I think I think you're fighting a
little too much Eric you're fighting too
much for your money and because of that
you're not getting your money I think
you just need to manifest a little bit
more so you can make the event free for
the rest of us and nobody is even saying
it needs to be free but why five
thousand dollars it's and that's like a
unjustifiable price 5,000 to 15,000
pounds or dollars or whatever you want
to call it it's just insane but what
gets me even more is when he tries to
tell you that oh actually if you pay
more you're gonna get more another thing
as well and this is one thing that my
mentors taught me many years ago is at
the end of the day a lot of people they
always ask for freebies and the universe
works in a very peculiar way in the
sense that - very peculiar way I just
thought about it I thought about how it
would best serve my motivations right
now and this is what I discovered
what you give out is what you get back
guys you got to give out man so in fact
if you write me a check right now for
twenty thousand dollars or pounds I will
make sure you manifest that right later
later on give it to me now but I will
manifest it later for you it's about
what you give guys it's about what you
get and at the end of the day if a lot
of people are just always looking for
free handouts it's a different response
that you get from the universe if you if
I keep giving it to you that this stuff
to you for free you know it's a
different response from the universe
guys come on come on I'm try and help
you out the universe is trying to help
you out but instead you keep trying to
get the stuff for free that which is why
I need to put you you know in debt guys
come on
more on this guy later but this is all
that good stuff for right now
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]